It's Mayuko's fault!
Killing that person makes you bad!
Help me!
It's true. I'm the bad one.
I'm bad for living on.
For killing people and living on.
I…
I'm…
From behind? How the hell did you do that?
Honjo, you are…
truly a God.
Mayuko, are you all right?
Take that gun and go up the stairs.
Thank you, Honjo. Will you be all right?
Oh, I'm fine.
Honjo!
Mayuko! I'm up!
We won't die.
We won't give in to this world!
Honjo!
You damn temptresses!
Did no one tell you that murder is wrong?
Even if you survive in this world,
you won't find any happiness here!
So, come and let's be happy.
Jump from the ledge with me--
My neck! It hurts!
I won't find happiness even if I survive?
I'm not so sure.
I'd say I'm very happy at the moment.
Meeting Honjo cleared things up for me.
My reason for living
is to secure my own happiness.
Commit suicide or get killed
and I won't be able to.
That's why I'll…
stay determined and keep fighting.